thiem jours de la guerre en ukraine la
capitale est donc sous couvre feu depuis
hier soir à kiev on retrouve tout de
suite notre envoyé spécial gwendoline de
bono gwendoline bonjour les rues de kiev
sont désertes depuis hier soir le
couvre-feu doit durer jusqu'à demain
matin
oui absolument à vous le voyez derrière
moi il n'y a absolument personne dans
les rues de la capitale les habitants ne
sont pas autorisés à sortir de chez eux
avant demain matin 7h alors c'est vrai
que d'habitude l effort sucré nien
utilisent ces couvre feu est bien pour
chercher ce qu'on appelle ici des
saboteurs russe ou pro russes ou des
unités de reconnaissance mais cette fois
ci selon le maire de la ville et bien
les autorités ont décrété ce couvre feu
parce qu'elles craignent des frappes sur
la ville des phrases plus intense de la
part des forces russes et c'est vrai que
ce matin on a donc on a entendu la
sirène d' alerte sonnait plusieurs fois
suivi de lourdes explosions alors c'est
toujours extrêmement difficile de savoir
de quoi il s'agit rapidement mais c'est
ce que l'on a entendu ce matin à
avant-hier effectivement il y a eu le
bombardement de ce centre commercial qui
a été totalement détruit huit personnes
sont mortes et les les plusieurs
plusieurs appartements un plusieurs
immeubles autour ont été ont été
endommagés donc c'est vrai qu'il y à
cette crainte dans la capitale de voir
ce type de frappes s'intensifier
notamment parce qu'autour de kiev et
bien les lignes de front sont pour
l'instant bloqués malgré quelques contre
attaques réussies de la part des forces
d'ukrainiens et gwendoline les combats
se poursuivent dans les faubourgs de
kiev l'armée russe tente toujours
d'encercler la ville
oui absolument et hier nous nous
trouvions à l'entrée de la ville d'hier
pin donc qui est l'une des lignes de
front principal qui se situe au nord
ouest de de kiev et là on voit aussi que
malgré une utilisation très intense de
l'artillerie et bien les forces russes
tiennent deux quartiers de la ville mais
ils ne font pas de grands progrès dans
cette ville on a assisté hier à des
combats assez limité
ce que l'on nous dit d'après plusieurs
sources en fait les forces ukrainienne
essaie d'empêcher les forces russes de
placer leurs positions d'artillerie
proche de la capitale kiev et elle
essaye également et bien de les empêcher
d'encercler la ville pour l'instant les
forces ukrainienne tiennent mais ce
qu'on voit se dessiner pour la capitale
et bien c'est un siège d'artillerie qui
pourrait durer assez longtemps avec un
emploi deux missiles et deux frappes sur
la capitale de plus en plus régulières
merci